Okay, I need to tighten what I'm gonna say.
America's leadership in the 21st Century is
not a choice between ignoring the rest of
the world, except when we kill terrorists,
or occupying and rebuilding whatever society
is unraveling.
Leadership means a wise application of military
power.
The problem for Barack Obama is that he says
our policy shouldn't be about killing terrorists,
it should be about more.
But that's all policy has been over his tenure.
Sure, we killed Osama bin Laden, but look
who's in power in Syria.
Look who's taking over parts of Iraq.
The President is exactly right.
Leadership does mean a wise application of
military power, but it also means resourcing
that military power.
It means leadership when Russia invades the
Ukraine.
It means leadership when American soldiers
and sailors are taken prisoner by Iran.
It means leadership against terrorism.
It means fighting against tyrannies the world
over because otherwise they come to our shores.
And that's the challenge that the next president
faces, is that we haven't pushed back on China,
we haven't pushed back on Russia, we haven't
pushed back on anyone.
What do you think about President Obama's
legacy?
Let us know in the comments section.
Don't miss my colleagues responding to the
President's State of the Union in these other
videos.